So, da bin ich, exzellent, so, ihr habt ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden Zeit, na,
zwei Stunden, zwei Stunden, vielleicht sogar ein bisschen länger, eineinhalb Stunden ist
ein bisschen kurz, Zeit, bevor ich pennen gehen muss, weil ich morgen früh wieder aufstehen
muss und arbeite, aber zum Glück immer noch Homeoffice komplett, das ist echt angenehm
im Vergleich zu 5x45 aufstehen, dann erst einmal, dann erst einmal eine Runde MonkaDB fahren,
ah, yes, exzellent, ja, also ich bin ja dafür, dass es dauerhaft Homeoffice gibt, Homeoffice
beste, hat für alle nur Vorteile, also jetzt in meinem Fall, ich sage es nicht für jeden
einzeln persönlich, aber in meinem Fall hat es für alle beteiligt nur Vorteile, ich bin
fitter, ich mache mehr, mir tut weniger der Rücken weh, ich habe Zeit mich zu bewegen,
ich muss keine kack Bahnstrecke fahren, oh Patrick, du hast deine Klimaanlage aktiviert,
exzellent, dann lass uns doch mal zusammen jetzt dual unsere Klimaanlagen aktivieren,
ich mach das jetzt auch, Achtung, so, ist eingeschaltet, spart auch Büro Miete, ja, richtig, ich habe
letztens einen guten Artikel drüber gesehen, glaubt, kann sogar Bakulem oder so gewesen
sein, warum Homeoffice eine sinnvolle Geschichte ist, natürlich ist das nicht für jeden, war
das, weiß gar nicht, war das Bakulem, ne, zumindest habe ich letztens einen guten Artikel
darüber gelesen und da wurden auch unter anderem so Sachen angeführt wie Mieten werden
weniger, Leute sind entspannter, bei vielen klappt auch die Zusammenarbeit lustigerweise
besser, gibt einige Sachen, aber es ist natürlich nicht für jeden was, ja, umweltschonender,
es gab ganz viele, ganz viele Punkte, so, natürlich ist es nicht für jeden was, es
gibt auch genug Berufe, wo das erst mal standardmäßig nicht geht und ansonsten muss es jeder selbst
wissen, ansonsten muss es jeder selbst wissen, wie das für ihn am besten passt, also ich
muss sagen, wenn die Corona-Geschichte vorbei ist, dann werde ich anstreben, dass ich auch
mindestens noch einen Homeoffice-Tag machen kann, einen festen, am liebsten zwei, ob das
geht, mal gucken, das ist wirklich viel, viel angenehmer und für alle Seiten besser.
Was man aber daran sieht ist, und das habe ich mich ja schon öfters im Stream dazu ausgelassen,
man sieht jetzt zum ersten Mal, und ich rede hier nur von Leuten, die ihr Geld damit verdienen,
weil sie technische Dinge angeblich können, wer technische Dinge denn quasi im Handumdrehen
beherrscht und wer, wer nicht, ja, und ich habe es im Stream schon total oft gesagt,
die Online-Gamer, also quasi die, die immer, die jahrelang quasi nur belächelt worden
sind, so nach dem Motto Lul-Online-Spieler, irgendwelche, früher wurde sich darüber lustig
gemacht, so nach dem Motto ballern bis die Aliens kommen, Warcraft 3, ja, da wurde sich
früher darüber lustig gemacht, aber ohne Scheiß in Homeoffice-Zeiten, die Elite von
heute sind Online-Gamer, ich merke es sofort, wenn ich mit Leuten irgendwie was über den
Chat regeln muss oder über Teams telefonieren muss, irgendwas, irgendwas online mit Leuten
zusammenarbeiten, ich merke sofort, wer Online-Spiele spielt und wer nicht, sofort, das merke
ich innerhalb der ersten 30 Sekunden, wenn ich es nicht schon, wenn ich es nicht schon
im Chat gemerkt habe, der Tein sei 12 Monate dabei, exzellent, wir müssen es gerade mal
verschieben, weil eigentlich habe ich die Emotes doch immer da, mit Boomer Homeoffice,
ja, wie gesagt, ich rede ja nicht unbedingt von Leuten, die jetzt irgendwie übermäßig
alt sind, wir haben auch genug Mittelalte, die es nicht gebacken kriegen, die es bis
heute nicht schaffen, den Mikrofon zu muten mal in irgendeiner Besprechung mit 30 Leuten
drin, ja, aber ich merke es innerhalb der ersten 30 Sekunden, wer Online-Spieler ist
und wenn ich, es geht, die Zusammenarbeit mit Leuten, die Online-Sachen schon gespielt
haben, die läuft einfach viel intuitiver und reibungsfreier, bei den anderen, da kommt
immer zu fragen, ja, wie meinst du das denn jetzt, oder, ha, ich kann es jetzt leider
nicht sehen, oder, wie ist, das ist so hakelig ist das irgendwie, woran erkennst du das,
das ist echt schwer zu sagen, das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen, woran ich das erkenne, aber
ich merke es irgendwie, sorry, danke schön, excellent subscription, wir haben 69 Zuschauer
gerade, ich merke das, ich kann es wirklich, ich muss mir überlegen, woran merke ich das,
mehr einfach wie die Leute in der Lage sind, sowas wie Teams zu verwenden, vor allem wie
die im Chat sich verhalten, Leute, die auch Remote arbeiten, die werden es kennen, wenn
du dann irgendwelche Leute hast, die im Chat schreiben, seid gegrüßt Kollegen, oder einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen Kollegen, oder, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, das System XY
ist zurzeit instabil, bitte schnellstmöglich das Problem beheben, mit freundlichen Grüßen
ihr Hotline Team, oder sowas, Alter, wenn sowas, wenn sowas im Chat kommt, da weiß ich
schon gleich, es ist wieder Boomer Alarm, ey, man merkt, easy killer, genau, man merkt
das wie schnell jemand schreibt, wie jemand schreibt, ob er Emojis verwendet, ob er die
oldschool Variante noch irgendwelche MMO Smileys oder so, oder Sachen verwendet, wie geschrieben
wird, ob groß klein mit Komma geschrieben wird, ob, wie schnell das Ganze geht, wie
schnell der in der Lage ist, quasi verschiedene Sachen im Chat von sich zu geben, also sprich,
er kann im Chat schreiben und nebenbei einen Link raussuchen und sowas, alles kein Problem,
ich merke das, ich merke das meistens schon, wie die Leute im Chat sind, und spätestens
wenn du mit denen dann telefonierst und mit ihnen was zusammen gucken willst, dann erst
recht, heut morgen habe ich wieder absolut Anfälle gekriegt, ey, ich hätte, ich hätte,
am liebsten hätte ich aufgelegt, wa, mich hat heute Morgen jemand angerufen, ich muss
jetzt gerade mal versuchen, dass ich das möglichst anonymisiert so irgendwie wiedergebe, weil
wenn ich das Software Produkt zahle, kann es durchaus sein, dass ihr das kennt, also,
ja Kommentator, das nicht unbedingt, aber auch das, auch das, auch das, gibt es einen
Spar AliExpress, so, ich mache jetzt übrigens bloß bei irgendeiner randomen Seite auf, wo
war ich denn gerade dabei, äh, heute Morgen, genau, äh, was wollte ich erzählen?
Heute Morgen war, irgendwelche Git-Geschichten wollte ich euch doch gerade erzählen, was
wollt, was wollt, fuck, mein, ey, Big Brain oder Low Brain, was, was, genau, ich habe
heute Morgen irgendwelche Git-Geschichten, was heute Morgen wollte ich euch erzählen,
ähm, genau, ja, ich, ich, genau, genau, genau, ich, ich weiß es wieder, es hat mich jemand
angerufen, ähm, und hat, also, hat mich erstmal im Chat gefragt, äh, erstmal im Chat gefragt,
bist du da?
Okay, das ist ja schonmal nicht schlecht, das ist ja, wenn ein Performer anruft, ist
ja, okay, ja, okay, und daran sieht man schonmal das erste, woran ich erkenne, wer Online-Spiel-Erfahrung
hat und wer nicht, wer Online-Spiel-Erfahrung hat, neigt in der Regel dazu, Sachen erstmal
im Chat zu schreiben, weil sich die Sachen recht einfach klären lassen, ich mein, ohne
Scheiß, wer Online-Spiel-Erfahrung hat, der hat Tribulan, bist du da, nein, exzellent,
müssen wir mal antworten, oh, das Scam-Train, Krelak, sieben Monate abonniert, Dankeschön,
huge, ich bin gerade am erzählen, ich, äh, hab jetzt, glaub ich, was übersehen, Zorix
haben wir auch schon, Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs, der, der Jebait-Train ist gerade
am Start, äh, genau, also, und, fuck, das heutiges Konzentrieren ist echt, echt, echt
schwierig, ne, ähm, genau, Online-Spieler neigen dazu, Sachen erstmal für kurze Sachen
im Chat zu klären, so nach dem Motto, wenn mich jemand anschreibt, z. B. Max, bist du
da, kannst du mal kurz mein Merchrequest angucken, ähm, es gibt Fehler auf SurferXY und ich
weiß nicht genau, ob wir jetzt lieber, was weiß ich, die eine Datei rausschmeißen oder,
oder, oder irgendwie, lieber die Datei umbenennen, sag mal, kannst du mir, oder wie siehst du
das, ne, das versuchen Online-Spieler, versuchen die Sachen erstmal, wenn es was kurzes einfach
ist, erstmal im Chat zu klären, weil es für die Leute viel einfacher ist, nicht zum
Headset zu greifen und erstmal anzurufen und erstmal so, ah, hi, wie geht's, sondern
die Leute, die wollen einfach nur ganz kurz klären, so wie man das von Online-Games,
gerade von MMOs, und ich sag's ganz besonders, nicht nur Online-Spiele, sondern, ähm, sondern
gerade MMO-Spieler oder sag ich mal auch Leute, die, die, die Gruppen-PVP oder so gespielt
haben, die, da merkst du, wenn die im Chat sind, der, der sagt dir drei Sätze, du weißt
genau, was der meint und du sagst dann wieder, wieder ein paar Wörter drauf und der versteht
genau, was du meinst und dann ist man sich einig und gut, so, das dauert dann zwei Minuten
und alle sind happy, so, der, der ist viel zu faul zum Telefon zu greifen, der MMO-Spieler,
der kann schnell chatten und der kann sich im Chat normal ausdrücken, verzichtet in
der Regel meistens auch auf Groß-Kleinschreibung und Sonderzeichen und irgendwelche Dinge,
macht als, äh, Satz-Trennzeichen meistens Emotes, so, das ist so der MMO-Spieler, so,
zumindest, ähm, wurde ich dann angerufen heute Morgen und das war wirklich absolut
grausam, ähm, es ging, Rush wie, ja, das, wenn das einer schreiben würde, dann würde
ich das wenigstens, würde ich verstehen, was er meint, im Kontext wahrscheinlich, so,
zumindest, hat heute Morgen, hat mich, wer ein bisschen was damit gemacht hat, wird's
wahrscheinlich gleich erkennen, wo das Problem ist, aber ich werd's dann nochmal erklären,
äh, heute Morgen hat mich einer angeschrieben, hat gemeint, hier, er hätte dann einen Change
für, also, die aktuelle Version, der, nennen wir's mal, der Software, die gerade schon live
ist, also sprich, äh, live, live, laufendes, produktives System, dann ist er da, der hat
einen Change, der hat jetzt quasi Server erweitert, es ging in dem Fall um Mail-Server, der Server
erweitert und er braucht einen Patch, dass quasi seine neuen Server jetzt angesprochen
werden, nicht die alten, warum das so schlecht programmiert ist, dass das nicht on the fly
geht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber der hat einen Patch gebraucht, ok, und jetzt, jetzt
kam der Hit, da hab ich gesagt, ja, ok, ähm, sag mir mal das Comet, sag mir mal den Pranch
oder sag mir mal ein Pull-Request oder irgendwas dazu, hat er gemeint, ja, also, das wäre
nicht nur ein Comet, das ist kein Witz, ist kein Witz, oh, der Hype Train, exzellent,
Toxy, Dankeschön, exzellent, Subscriptions, das ist jetzt kein Witz, da meinte er, es
wäre nicht nur ein Comet, sondern, jetzt haltet euch fest, für ein paar neue Mail-Server,
120 Comets, da ist ein Moment, du willst jetzt allen Ernstes, dass ich 120 Comets von dir
in unseren Release-Pran schiebe oder was, ja, ok, man muss ihn zu gut halten, da ist
auch, also der ist wirklich, der ist wirklich Boomer, der ist keine Ahnung, 65 oder so,
und geht bald in Rente, aber trotzdem, war hart, Alter, ja, 120 Comets, WTF, 100, also
erstens, warum so viel und ich, ich, ich verstehs nicht, ähm, sag mir, such mir doch mal ein
paar relevante Comets raus, also 120 Comets mach ich da bestimmt nicht rein, ähm, such
mir doch mal ein paar relevante Comets raus, und da hat er mich gefragt, ja, wie mach ich
das denn, sagt ja, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, ich hab das nicht programmiert, also,
du kennst doch deine eigenen Änderungen noch, du, du musst doch wissen, du musst doch wissen,
was du programmiert hast, ah, also er kann mir den Pransch-Namen sagen, ok, da hat er
mir den Pransch-Namen gesagt, das war irgendein Pransch, den er ganz merkwürdig mal rebased
hat auf sonst was, keine Ahnung, da waren wirklich 120 Comets drinnen, das war richtig,
allerdings waren das gar keine 120 Comets, sondern das waren 120 Comets, die eigentlich
schon längst drinnen sind, aber dadurch, dass er merkwürdig rebased hat, hat Git das
nicht erkannt, weil er irgendwie, weil er Dinger gemacht hat, keine Ahnung, ja, so,
und dann hab ich gesagt, ok, also, damit kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht viel anfangen,
aber sag mir doch mal, den Merchrequest, den du dafür gemacht hast, der muss, da, da gucken
wir da rein, Merchrequest weiß er nicht, wo der ist, wo findet er den denn, also das
ist ja gut bei uns im Bitbucket, da wo alle Merchrequest sind, das ist doch nicht den,
ich bin da schon ein bisschen stinkig geworden, das ist doch nicht den ersten Merchrequest,
den du aufmachst, und da musste ich ins Bitbucket gehen, oder ihr könnt euch Bitbucket so vorstellen
wie GitLab oder GitHub oder so, macht keinen großen Unterschied, also überall wo es Pullrequest,
Merchrequest gibt, hab ich ihm die Seite copypasted von dem Merchrequest, Pullrequest Dialog
aus dem Bitbucket, und hab ihm den Link geschickt, und ich hab schon seinen Autor eingetragen,
also sprich, als Autor schon ihn reingeschrieben, so, und da hat er das aufgemacht, hat gemeint,
sein Merchrequest ist nicht dabei, also nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe, du willst, dass
ich irgendwelche Comments nach Produktion cherrypick, dass dein Mailzeug funktioniert,
du kannst mir nicht sagen, welche Comments relevant sind, du kannst mir nicht sagen,
welcher Pullrequest dazu gehört, du kannst mir nicht den Autor der Comments sagen, noch
nicht mal was im Titel vielleicht drinstehen könnte, ja woher soll ich denn wissen, was
du da jetzt brauchst, und dann hat er gesagt, ja, und dann hat er angefangen, pampig zu
werden, hat er gemeint, ja deswegen würde er mich doch anrufen, ich kenn mich damit
doch aus, und jetzt haltet euch fest, diese Person ist nicht etwa Kobol-Entwickler oder
sowas, sondern externer Experte, ja für was ist ja egal, also eingekaufter, der kriegt
keine Ahnung, 130k im Jahr oder so, ich hab keine Ahnung wieviel's genau sind, aber
sind wahrscheinlich saumäßig viel Kohle, ja, für keine Ahnung haben, so und dann hab
ich zu ihm gesagt, okay, weißt du was, ich hab dir doch jetzt die Seite mit den Pullrequests
geschickt, ich hab dir doch diese, also hier guck mal, GitHub, für die Leute, die nicht
wissen wie das Ganze aussieht, ich zeig euch das mal, sieht das bei uns intern auch aus,
wir nehmen jetzt mal irgendein Projekt, wo es einige Pullrequests gibt, nennen wir irgendein
Projekt, ja keine Ahnung was das ist, so guck, hier gibt es, ich hab übrigens kein Plastenschimmer,
ich hab das erstbeste Projekt aufgemacht, so sieht das bei uns auch aus, nur dass es
ein bisschen mehr ist, also heute morgen waren irgendwie 8 Pullrequests bei uns offen, da
steht dann drinnen, was man für neues Feature programmiert hat, vielleicht noch welche
Systeme das betrifft, was man sich dabei so gedacht hat, so sehen Pullrequests aus,
so und da hab ich ihm gesagt, okay, ich hab dir doch jetzt den Pullrequest Link im Bitbucket
geschickt, dann guck doch einfach mal die Pullrequests durch und du wirst ihn schon
finden, kann er nicht so lange her sein das Ganze, so und ich hab ihn dem Link so geschickt,
also ich hab ihm quasi schon den Link geschickt, wo er als Autor eingetragen war und dann
meint er auf einmal, ja aber ich seh doch da nur meine Pullrequests, da ist doch der
nicht dabei, ja dann nimm dich halt als Autor raus und dann hat er allen ernstes gefragt
und das ist kein Witz, ich schwöre Leute, es ist kein Witz, ich schwöre auf MonkaS,
ja, hat er gesagt, wie nehme ich den Autor raus, das ist kein Witz, wie nehme ich den
Autor raus und da hab ich ihm gesagt, klick auf das X neben Autor, hat er gesagt, das
geht nicht, dann war es mir irgendwann zu doof, alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man so unfähig
sein kann, ich versteh es echt nicht, es ist mir unbegreiflich, komplett unbegreiflich,
ich hab mir das extra nochmal aufgeschrieben, ich mach das manchmal gerne, wenn mich Sachen
besonders aufregen, dann schreib ich mir die auf, dann reg ich mich weniger auf drüber
und ich kann irgendwann mal drüber was erzählen, ich muss mal kurz gucken, was Vodafone macht,
hey funktioniert alles wunderbar, exzellent, wenn ihr mal ein Projekt mit vielen Pullrequests
sehen wollt, so, ja, ungefähr so wie die erste Seite, hier sieht es auch bei uns im
Headbucket aus auf der Arbeit, ja, und da hab ich mich auch wieder gefragt, alter, wie
unfähig kann man eigentlich sein, ach ja, und der Hit kam danach noch, danach hab ich
gesagt, hier weißt du was, ich geh mal kurz was essen, du kannst ja mal die Pullrequests
jetzt durchgucken und er wollte ja nicht, er wollte ja nicht, weil er hat gesagt, es dauert
ja so lang, aber auf der anderen Seite, hey, wenn er mir weder einen Comments sagen kann
noch ein Autor, noch ein Pullrequest, woher soll ich, dann wissen wir, was ich Cherry
picken soll, geschweige ich hätte eh nix Cherry gepickt, meiner Produktion so einfach,
aber das steht mal auf dem anderen Platt und zwei Minuten, da hab ich gesagt, ich geh
jetzt essen, guck mal durch, ob du es findest, zwei Minuten später sehe ich auf dem Handy,
er hat den Teams geantwortet, hier, ich hab's gefunden, zwei Minuten, aber erstmal zehn
Minuten rumdiskutieren, da kriegt er dafür doch Geld, dann guck ich in den Pullrequest
rein, als ich wieder oben war nach dem Essen, es geht auch nicht lang, zehn Minuten, guck
ich in den Pullrequest rein und wisst ihr was, es waren keine 120 Comments und es ging
auch um komplett was anderes, es war ein Commit drinnen und dieses Commit war sogar schon
aktuell im Produktionsbranche drinnen, das heißt, es war alles komplett umsonst, ja,
das hätte man auch selbst nachgucken können, man hätte einfach gucken können, ob der
Kram so tut, wie er es programmiert hat, dann hätte er nicht mal den Source Code sich
angucken müssen in Produktionsbranche, der hätte einfach nur gucken müssen, ob der
Kram so funktioniert, wie er programmiert hat und dann ist gut, exzellent, exzellent,
das sind externe Profis, ja, wir haben alle Geld verdient, das ist korrekt, das ist das
einzig positive, was man dieses ganze Ereignis abgewinnen kann, wir haben alle Geld dafür
gekriegt, was mich aber ärgert ist, dass er wahrscheinlich doppelt so viel gekriegt
hat, wie ich dafür, oder dreimal so viel, also gut, na klar, der muss Steuern bezahlen,
das doppelte, sag mal, das doppelte, Plopsrusher, fünf Monate, exzellent, guck mal, das passende
Mode ist schon da, ja, Leute, ok, so, das wollte ich jetzt nochmal loswerden, habt ihr
übrigens mitgekriegt, was das für eine Software ist, um die Software ging es nur zum Teil,
das war zum größten Teil Server-Config, beziehungsweise Load Balancer Server-Config, um das es heute
morgen ging, die aber relevant ist für das was drauf läuft, der Steam Summer Sale ist
jetzt live, ok, zeig mal her, gibt es denn irgendwas gescheites, Steam Summer Sale ist
gestartet, exzellent, zeig mal her, was gibt es denn da schönes, Borderlands, ach, haben
die es jetzt endlich auf Steam geschafft, Borderlands 3, das war ja vorher Epic exklusiv,
Borderlands 3 kann ich empfehlen, wirklich, wirklich nice, das Game, leider ist die Story
für ein Arsch, die ist jetzt zwar nicht extrem schlecht, die ist aber unnötig übertrieben,
teilweise unnötig in die Länge gezogen und eigentlich total uninteressant, ich hab's
aber noch im Epic Store gekauft, also ich hab nicht die Steam Variante, aber jedes Borderlands
ist doch fast dasselbe, naja, aber deswegen macht es das ja auch zu einem guten Game,
weil Borderlands an sich immer noch Borderlands ist, aber die Singleplayer Kampagne ist halt,
ist ja nicht Singleplayer, die Kampagne ist halt bisschen doof diesmal, so Destiny 2 ist
es nicht umsonst jetzt, doch, ich wollte doch gerade sagen, kostet doch nix, was haben wir
denn sonst noch hier schönes, habe ich nicht gespielt, hatte ich auch nicht vor, Tabletop
Simulator, Planet Coaster, das habe ich mir sogar gekauft auf Steam vor einem Jahr oder
so, hab nicht 5 Minuten gespielt, geht euch das auch so, dass ihr manchmal vorm Rechner
sitzt und sich so denkt, ey, irgendwie fehlt mir gerade so das richtige aktuelle Game,
was ich mal, wo ich mal ein paar Stunden drin versenken kann, sondern macht ihr Steam auf
und dann scrollt ihr 20 Minuten Steam durch und ihr findet 30 Milliarden Games, aber findet
alles kacke, es gibt, ich kann es echt schwer beschreiben, ich hab das Gefühl, heute haben
wir einen Mangel durch mehr, klingt beknackt, ich weiß, wir haben viel mehr Games und auch
alle möglichen Genres und tausende Sachen, aber es gibt weniger, das ist sehr merkwürdig,
Tragen Quest Builder soll ganz nett sein, Max Respect V, nein, was macht da die LOL-Dings,
ach das ist hier eine DJ-Game, ach du große, was meine Musik ist zu leise, nee, ist überhaupt
nicht, passt doch, ist doch eigentlich genau richtig, ich bin so, Musik ist so, Chat ist
meine Musik zu leise, du hörst, dann musst du lauter machen, excellent, was ist das hier,
was ist das, Steam ist wieder wahnsinnig geschwind, Open World RPG, das habe ich mir gekauft und
ich muss sagen, das hat auch 3-4 Tage Spaß gemacht, aber irgendwie hat es dem Game so
ein bisschen an Finesse gefehlt, fand ich, du konntest, das Game war übelst easy mode,
wenn du einfach nur irgendwie den Sperr genommen hast und von der Seite draufgerusht bist,
zurückgelaufen bist, draufgerusht bist, wahrscheinlich ist es mittlerweile schwieriger, aber hat
sich nicht so gut gespielt, fand ich, wie sieht es mit Profilesignieren aus, ja, muss
ich mal machen, ich weiß, haben ganz viele Leute reingeschrieben, mache ich demnächst,
das habe ich mir auch zur Release gekauft, das wollte ich schon ewig mal spielen, habe
ich noch nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich auch nicht, das ist
irgendwelche Survival Games, davon gibt es, sag mal, dieses Game mit dem Hai, gab es das
nicht schon mal, hieß das nicht irgendwie Reef oder irgendwie sowas, Reft, Reft, Reft,
ja genau, nee, Moment, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich nicht, oder meine ich das,
oder meine ich vielleicht tatsächlich das hier, nee, das meine ich nicht, aber das war
so ein Game, da sitzt man nur auf dem Floß, vielleicht ist das das, oder Early Access,
meinst du, nee, ich meine ein Game, da sitzt man nur auf dem Floß und man kann das Floß
ausbauen, also man baut dann immer, man sammelt dann Treibholz auf und baut das Floß aus
und manchmal kommt ein Hai, das war Reft, echt, ok, oh, Steam kackt ab, ja, das, ja,
das meine ich, genau das meine ich, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass man seine, seinen Floß
ausbauen konnte, ja, aber so ungefähr sah das aus, das hat mich, also das hier hat mich
jetzt extrem daran erinnert, irgendwie, also das ist, das geht schon, das geht schon in
die gleiche Richtung, was, Streamdown, ach, Steamdown, das geht doch schon in die gleiche
Richtung hier, aber ich muss sagen, so Survival Games ist auch nicht wirklich meins, Featured
Franchise, Total War, ist das nicht der Kram, wo man, oder ist das nicht, genau, ist das
nicht das Game mit den Warhammer Ablegern, wo es irgendwie 500 Euro kostet mit allen
DLCs, oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander, Warms, das gibt es immer noch, das ist gefühlt
auch ein Spiel, das ist aus der Steinzeit, wisst ihr, jetzt wo ich gerade Warhammer hier
sehe, wisst ihr was, eine Sache, die mir, die mir nicht einleuchtet, Dungeons & Dragons
ist gerade, so die letzten 3-4 Jahre, ist das durch die, auch die ganzen YouTube-Serien
und Twitch-Geschichten, wo das gespielt wird, quasi von so dem, dem Keller Kind Game zu
fast schon Mainstream geworden, also sagen wir mal die letzten 10 Jahre über vielleicht,
aber so die letzten 3-4 Jahre, ist es fast schon, fast schon normal, dass bisschen jüngere
mal Dungeons & Dragons gespielt haben, als dass sie es nicht gespielt haben, fast, ja,
und was ich da nicht verstehe ist, warum gibt es so wenige Dungeons & Dragons Games, sind
die so ex-, ich weiß, dass jetzt Baldur's Gate 3 irgendwann kommt, ja, aber sind die,
sind die so pingelig, was ihre Lizenz angeht, es gibt ab und zu mal welche, aber die sind
allesamt kacke, warum gibt es da so wenige von, ja, es gibt total viele Pen & Paper Varianten,
allerdings ist Dungeons & Dragons somit das bekannteste, warum gibt es da so wenige Games
von, das letzte richtig gute, das ist aber ein Regelwerk Fork gewesen, war Dings hier,
äh, Moment, wie hieß das nochmal, das, wo alle gesagt haben, das wäre so ultra schwer
und war es dann gar nicht, das habe ich auch mal kurz, da habe ich auch mal ein paar Stunden
gespielt, wie hieß das denn, Passfinder, genau, das fand ich richtig gut, das hat auf Steam
immer noch schlechte Bewertung, man muss sagen, ok, das war am Anfang auch, weil man halt
sehr viele Story Branches haben konnte, ein bisschen verbackt, ja, aber ich muss sagen,
das war eines der besten Classic RPGs, wie man das ja neuerdings so schön nennt, das
sind ja nicht mehr einfach nur RPGs, sondern Classic RPGs, eines der besten, die ich die
letzten Jahre so gespielt habe und ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht direkt offizielles Dungeons
& Dragons Regelwerk, das ist Passfinder, das ist quasi ein Dungeons & Dragons, glaube
ich, 3-Fork und man sieht es ja auch hier, das sieht halt schon sehr klassisch aus, das
Game war richtig gut und das geht lang und du kannst saumäßig viele Sachen machen,
du hast total viele verschiedene Charaktermöglichkeiten, war richtig gut und die Leute, da hat man
wieder gesehen, wie dumm, wie brain dead manche Spiele heute sind, ähm, verstehe nicht warum
die Steam Server immer wieder zusammenbrechen, ja, weil jetzt gerade alle mal reingucken
wollen in Steam Sale, ähm, so und du hattest hier Leute drin am Anfang, die haben sich
allen ernstes beschwert, ich mein, ich muss mal sagen, das ist halt ein recht klassisches
RPG, man kann bei der Charaktererstellung auch was verscheißen, das ist nicht so wie
bei moderneren MMOs, wo du quasi fast alles komplett solo spielen kannst, also du kannst,
du konntest das bei der Charaktererstellung schon ein bisschen verscheißen, also wenn
du jetzt gesagt hast, ok, ich mach einen Zauberer mit Kettenrüstung, der da nicht zaubern kann
und dafür halt mit Level 1 nur draufhaut und sich total vergimmt, ok, dann hast du
Schwierigkeiten gehabt, aber ansonsten, die Leute haben so krass rumgeheult bei Release
und da waren wirklich die Leute der Beinung am Anfang, das Spiel ist nicht spielbar,
weil, ähm, man in der ersten Höhle, in die man gekommen ist, Spinnen bekämpfen musste
und die Spinnen musste man bekämpfen, indem man Feuerzauber drauf macht, AE Feuerzauber,
also sprich das Game sagt einem vorher auch noch, ähm, Spinnen respawn und du musst,
das ist quasi eher ein Tutorial für Flächenzauber gewesen, das ganze und da haben die Leute
steif und fest in den Steam-Bewertungen behauptet, das Spiel wäre unfair bis zur Unkenntlichkeit
unspielbar, so nach dem Motto, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, Pains Champ, wie zurückgeblieben
sind die meisten Spieler heutzutage, was das angeht, äh, das Spiel sagt dir, das sagt,
ich glaube, ich lagelt mich jetzt nicht drauf fest, aber ich glaube, es gibt sogar noch
beim Betreten der Höhle einen Dialog, dass du entweder Flächenfeuerzauber nehmen sollst
oder, ähm, du hast, äh, oder du kannst quasi aus der Kiste ein paar Brandsätze looten,
die du werfen kannst, das sagt dir das Game noch und die Leute waren steif und fest, haben
behauptet, nein, es ist unmöglich, das Spiel zu spielen, Insomniac Dude sagt, das waren
sicher die Zoomer, garantiert waren das die Zoomer, das wäre einem Boomer wirklich nicht
passiert, der Boomer hätte wahrscheinlich noch erklären können, dass es Feuerball erst
am Level 6 oder so gibt, nee, das waren definitiv Zoomer und dann auch noch, ähm, etwas degenerierte
Zoomer, würde ich sagen, also wer auf Classic RPGs steht und das noch nicht gespielt hat,
das ist das beste Classic Roleplay Gedöns nach einem ordentlichen Regelwerk, was es
die letzten 5 Jahre gegeben hat, das kann ich jedem nur ans Herz legen, könnt ihr mal
gucken, vielleicht ist das irgendwann hier auch im Sale, aktuell, ist es ja auch, guck
mal, also aktuell 11.99, kann man wirklich nicht sagen, die kümmern sich auch wahnsinnig
gut um ihr Game, es gab schon ein paar Erweiterungen, es gab neue Klassen, ähm, es gibt sogar
ein paar DLCs, die auch noch ganz gut Content bringen und die, wenn man sich hier mal die
Patches anguckt, die sind auch kontinuierlich dran, ihr Game noch zu patchen, also da kann
man wirklich nichts sagen und das hat mir wieder gezeigt, dass die meisten Gamers in
dieser Richtung mittlerweile total, äh, brain dead sind.
Es muss ja nicht jedes Spiel extrem schwer sein und es zeichnet sich jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt ein gutes Spiel dadurch aus, dass es unzugänglich wäre oder so, aber das Game
erklärt es dir und die Leute waren immer noch komplett unfähig.
Gut, ich meine, ich hab auch schon die ein oder anderen klassischen RPGs gespielt, ja,
angefangen von Icewind, Dale, Baldur's Gate und hast du nicht gesehen, System Shock, alle
möglichen Dinge, vielleicht sind für mich manche Mechaniken klar, die bei anderen nicht
so klar sind, aber das Game sagt es dir vorher und dann rumzuhäulen, es wäre quasi unspielbar,
ist halt echt der Witz, dabei ist es eines der besten RPGs der letzten Jahre.
So, was gibt es hier als sonst noch, Final Fantasy Franchise, da legt die Betonung auf
Scheiß, ähm, weil die neuen Final Fantasy Spiele gefallen mir gar nicht, das ist eines
der guten Final Fantasy Games, muss man wirklich sagen, auch wenn wir es relativ, ähm, hast
du schon Abmahnungen bekommen wegen Musik in Clips, nö, Abmahnungen kriegst du daher
nicht, da kriegst du wenn schon Streiks, warum fragst du, Sebaru, ich spiele doch auch nichts
im Stream, was irgendwie Copyright großartig wäre, ich spiele irgendwelche komischen Chills
der Playlist von YouTube, wo du sogar noch laufend angeschrieben wirst von irgendwelchen
Leuten, ob man nicht ihre Sache mal verwenden will, ne, ne, ich hab nix, ich hab nix gekriegt,
ja die Nintendo Songs, aber da ist, das sind alles meistens Super Nintendo Songs, da sind
die gerade auf Twitch, also wenn die anfangen jetzt Game Songs zu streiken auf Twitch, auf
einer Spiele Streaming Plattform, wie soll denn das dann funktionieren, also wenn ich
wirklich Game Soundtracks auf Twitch streike, dann kann keiner mehr, keiner mehr streamen,
also auch wenn der Friseur und ich das nicht so lange gespielt haben, weil es faktisch
kaum Endgame gegeben hat zur damaligen Zeit, Final Fantasy IV, also das online, das zweite
Final Fantasy Online Game, das ist wirklich gut und mittlerweile soll es da wohl auch
ordentlich Endgame geben, wir haben das damals gespielt als das erste Addon rausgekommen
ist und ihr kennt uns ja, also wenn wir sowas spielen, dann spielen wir das quasi 24-7 und
wir hatten irgendwie nach, keine Ahnung, einem Monat alles durch, was das Spiel hatte, inklusive
Endgame Dungeons, die man täglich nur dreimal machen konnte oder so und der Fabian hatte
da nix besseres zu tun, wie sein Charakter erstmal einen Race Change zu spendieren und
sich dann nackt in die Stadt zu stellen und dort AFK, ist jetzt kein Witz, und dort AFK
für drei Stunden rumzustehen, nackig, da muss es einem schon echt langweilig sein.
Gut, wie das neue Final Fantasy, das letzte Final Fantasy ist, ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
also hier das, das, was sind das für eine Zahl, 15, keine Ahnung wie das ist, hab ich
auch nicht gespielt, hab ich auch keinen großartigen Bedarf zu, so da gibt es irgendwelche Games,
die mich allein schon von der Optik nicht ansprechen, Street Fighter, Fighting Games
sind auch nicht, Warhammer Underworld Online, ah dann Kartenspiel, das dürften, das konnten
die sich natürlich nicht, nee das ist so ne Mischung aus, richtigen Warhammer, ok vielleicht
haben sie mal was gescheites hingekriegt, keine Ahnung, aber wahrscheinlich 30 Milliarden
DLCs, was wahnsinnig teuer ist, Zoo Tycoon, das ist das Game, wo die Tiere durch die
Zäune klitschen können, ne, Shadow of War, hab ich mir auch mal vor Uhrzeiten gekauft
und gespielt, Walking Dead, ist ja auch irgendwie uninteressant, Just Cause 4, es suckt auch,
guckt euch mal die Reviews an, richtig mies, ich glaube sogar, dass ich mir das hier gekauft
hab, das kommt mir bekannt vor, ich glaub das hab ich mir gekauft und auch noch nicht
gespielt, ich hab mir so viele Games auf Steam gekauft und nie gespielt, es ist eigentlich
total sinnlose Geldverschwendung, what the fuck, Open World Horror RPG, was denn noch
alles zusammen, Open World Horror Role Playing, ok, die ganzen Horror Games ist halt auch so,
das Ding spricht mich auch überhaupt nicht an, ahja ja, würde ich sagen, ne, hab ich
verdrückt, Golf It, ein Multiplayer Mini Golf Game, ahja, ahja beste Leute, hab ich jetzt
ordentlich gegrindet die letzten zwei Tage, da wo ich nicht online war, hab ich ordentlich
gegrindet, ich hab jetzt meinen Char fast am Endgame und da geht das Gefahr mehr, in
dem Game geht es erst richtig los, so, Pummelparty, das hab ich schon ein paar mal, ich hab mir
noch keinen Stream davon angeguckt, aber ich hab auf Twitch total oft gesehen, dass die
Pummelparty als Spiel drin hatten, das ist glaub ich auch nur irgendein Multiplayer Funny
Multiplayer Spiel für zwischendurch so, das ist Mario Party ohne Mario, ah verstehe,
Summersale, Hunter, das ist das was der Kaboom spielt oder, ich glaub das ist das was der
Kaboom spielt, ich hab letztens mit dem Kaboom telefoniert und er meinte, er spielt jetzt
irgendwelche Jäger Games und setzt sich auf den Hochstand, ich glaub das ist das Spiel
was er meint, ok das ist nicht unbedingt mein Fall, Satisfactory, dann spiel ich lieber
Factorio, Factorio ist auch ein super Game wer es noch nicht hat, Doom Eternal, ja also
das kann man echt machen, ja die Hälfte davon, das ist ok, das kann man echt machen, ja ich
bin unbedingt 1913 geboren, weil ich das noch nicht wusste, das kann man echt machen,
also Doom Eternal kann man empfehlen, es hat ein bisschen Anlaufschwierigkeiten, also
so die ersten 1, 2, wenn man langsam ist 2,5 Stunden, vielleicht sogar 3 Stunden sind
ein bisschen langweilig, aber danach ist mega geil, das ist aber bei dem Game auch erforderlich,
weil das hat so viele Mechanics, von Waffenswitchen bis Waffen Upgraden, bis unterschiedliche
Launcher, bis Flammenwerfer, bis Eisbomben, bis Granaten, bis sonst was, du hast 30 Milliarden
Sachen die du machen kannst, da hast du noch deinen rummischen Enterhaken, alles mögliche,
also das Game braucht erst ein bisschen was um das zu erklären, Cyberpunk, mein Cyberpunk
ist im Steam Sale und es ist nicht günstiger, warum soll ich das denn jetzt kaufen, Moment
ist das überhaupt Sale, Moment wir müssen erstmal auf Sale drücken, dass wir auf den
Sale kommen, ich bin ja pepega, ich dachte die ganze Zeit ist, ist bei Pass of Exile noch
der Char immer weg nach der Season, nein, der Char ist nie weg nach der Season in Pass
of Exile, du kannst Standard spielen, dann ist dein Charakter prinzipiell immer da und
geht auch nie weg, oder du kannst Season spielen, dann wird dein Charakter aber auch nie gelöscht,
du kannst den Charakter danach in Standard weiter spielen, wenn du willst, aber ansonsten
ist es ja der Sinn von Seasons, dass man neu anfängt, dass es quasi ein Reset gibt, aber
dein Charakter ist nicht weg, also wenn du einen Charakter gelevelt hast und du willst
einfach mal ein neues Bild ausprobieren, kannst du den theoretisch verwenden in Standard
und gucken wie er im Endgame sich spielt, kannst du machen, sofern du die Skillpunkte
verteilt kriegst, ne also der Charakter ist nicht weg, nutzt du Pass of Building, klar
muss man, ohne Pass of Building wirst du aufgeschmissen, vor allem wenn du irgendwelche
Bilder nachbastelt, kommt man in das Game gut rein, ja und ne, Pass of Exile ist total
einfach einzusteigen, aber, aber, man hat, also wenn man das einfach nur spielen will,
wenn man das einfach nur spielen will und jetzt nicht irgendwie krass im Endgame abgehen
will, also sprich, dass man, dass man dann irgendwie innerhalb ein paar Tage dann irgendwelche
roten Maps machen kann im Endgame oder so, wenn man einfach nur mal ein bisschen Hack
and Slam machen will, ist Pass of Exile super zum Einstieg, ist auch nicht schwierig, also
die Basics die man braucht sind ganz gut erklärt, so, allerdings sollte man nicht verschweigen,
dass Pass of Exile ein ziemlicher Wust an Features ist mittlerweile, du hast 50 Varianten
wie du was kräften kannst, du hast tausende Skills, tausende aktive, also übertrieben
gesagt, aber so viel weniger ist es gar nicht, Kombinationen aus Skills, Skilltrees, Gems
sonst was, es ist sehr unübersichtlich, deswegen kann ich dir nur empfehlen, nimm dir ein Einsteiger
Guide, vielleicht noch mit einem Einsteiger Bild dabei und probier das ganze mal aus
und deswegen ist gerade auch Pass of Building gut, weil in Pass of Building, ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich hier einen Charakter drinne hab, weil in Pass of Building kannst du sehen,
wenn du dir ein Bild rausgesucht hast, ne ich glaub ich hab hier nix drin, wenn du ein Bild
rausgesucht hast von jemand der weiß was er macht, was ich empfehlen würde, also ich
würde bei diesem Skilltree nicht anfangen mir selbst ein Bild zusammen zu bauen, wenn
man das noch nicht gemacht hat, so und dann kannst du hier sehen was der für Skills hat,
für Items hat und kannst das nachbauen, z.B. ich zeig euch das mal, also was ich verwende
für diese League, wie heißt er, YouTube, ist ein Bild von dem Typ hier, der streamt
auch auf Twitch, ist eigentlich so einer der größeren Pass of Exile Streams, was ich hier
bei dieser League als Starter nehme ist das da, das ist das absolute Noob Bild, so wie
ich das auf Reddit rausgekriegt habe, das einzige Problem ist, es ist etwas GPU intensiv,
also man sieht es ja hier schon im Hintergrund, dass der halbe Bildschirm explodiert und alle
Gegner platzen, aber z.B. dass man mal angenommen ihr sagt ok ich will einsteigen, dann nehmt
euch ein fertiges Bild und dann guckt ihr in die Beschreibung und nehmt hier das Pass
of Building Bild von dem jeweiligen Bild, so und dann macht ihr Pass of Building auf
und sagt, Moment wo war das jetzt, aber das ist immer ein bisschen versteckt, import,
vom Pastebin, import, zack, also dann habt ihr das fertige Bild, dann habt ihr das hier
unten, oh ich muss meine Version glaube ich updaten, ne passt, so dann habt ihr nämlich
genau das Update von Level 1 bis Level 10, danach, danach, danach, danach, also sprich
ihr seht genau in welcher Reihenfolge ihr was skillen müsst bis zum Endgame, also sprich
ihr fangt hier an, also ihr fangt als Witch an und die ersten paar Levels skillt ihr das,
so und wenn ihr das gemacht habt, dann skillt ihr hier weiter und so weiter und so weiter,
d.h. man kann ihm relativ einfach folgen, dazu gibt es bei den meisten Guides noch ein
ordentliches Video oder ein ordentlich geschriebener Guide, der euch ein bisschen was drumherum
erklärt, dann könnt ihr nachgucken quasi welche Skills empfohlen werden zum Leveln
und wie das Endgame Setup aussieht, inklusive Item Vorschläge für Early Game und Endgame
Gear, also Passive Building ist wirklich das beste Tool, wenn man keinen Plan von dem Game
hat, allerdings ein gutes Bild spielen will, das nachzubauen, doch Jurok ich bin mir nicht
sicher, ich könnte sogar den Community Fork haben, habe ich den Community Fork, wo sieht
man das, aber ja du hast recht, braucht er oder die haben es schon geupdatet, oder die
haben es schon geupdatet, das kann auch sein, es könnte sein, dass die es geupdatet haben.
Schreibt ihr was von Fork, ach hier guck, Passive Building Community Fork, ja das ist
eh die bessere Variante von, ja und danach könnt ihr zumindest Passive Exile erstmal
relativ normal spielen, ihr habt nicht die, ihr müsst nicht die Bedenken haben, dass
ihr euch verskillt, weil ich meine im Endeffekt, oh habe ich es jetzt gelöscht, oh ich kacke
nur, ich wollte euch doch noch was zeigen, also wie gesagt ihr müsst nicht die Bedenken
haben, dass ihr euch verskillt, dadurch dass ihr schon ein fertiges Build habt von jemanden
der weiß was er macht und es halt auch genau da steht in welcher Reihenfolge hier was
geskillt wird und sonst was und dann könnt ihr euch einfach langsam anfangen ein bisschen
mit dem Game auseinander zu setzen und Passive Exile hat wirklich extrem viel mit dem man
sich auseinandersetzen kann, nicht unbedingt muss, man kann viele Aspekte in dem Game komplett
außen vor lassen, also man kann auch zum Beispiel sagen ok, ich will mich gar nicht
so extrem intensiv damit beschäftigen, Items selbst zu craften oder selbst zu enchanten
sondern ich farm einfach meinen Content und kaufe mir die Sachen dann, ja bei allem geht
es nicht aber für normales 0-15 Gear ist das kein Problem, ihr könnt auch diesen Delph
Dungeon machen oder müsst ihr aber auch nicht machen, das ist so ein Endlos Dungeon, wo
man quasi mit so einem Minenwagen immer tiefer in den Dungeon reinfährt, muss man auch überhaupt
nicht machen also man kann viele Aspekte kann man machen, muss man aber nicht unbedingt
aber Passive Exile hat halt extrem viele Sachen die man machen kann und eine Sache muss man
auch nochmal wirklich den Entwicklern wirklich hoch anrechnen, der Übergang von der Story
also von der Kampagne in das Endgame bis zum Schluss vom Endgame ist wirklich gut gemacht
also du wirst quasi von der Kampagne in den Endgame Atlas Modus richtig gut reingeführt
und dann auch kriegst du das auch nochmal erklärt, eins muss man allerdings sagen,
die Kampagne ist scheiße, die Kampagne ist wirklich Müll, also wenn ein Spiel wegen
der Story spielt, der ist bei Passive Exile falsch aufgehoben und ja Passive Exile hat
eine Kampagne, Passive Exile hat sogar eine Story, aber die ist so konfus und schlecht
dass glaube ich die Entwicklern selbst nicht genau verstehen was da eigentlich passiert
ist.
Hast du den Windows Defender auf Lilux ausprobiert?
Ja wollte ich gestern, bis ich rausgefunden habe, das ganze kostet Geld, man muss sich
registrieren oder für eine Trial muss man eine Firma sein und Microsoft muss einen manuell
freischalten.
Also wie gesagt wegen der Story müsst ihr jetzt echt nicht spielen, ich schalte mal
hier, wow das hab ich hier mit meinem Vm gemacht, warum sind hier eigentlich so viele Kekwes?
Ach steht gar nicht drinnen, es gab eben doch noch eine Frage, wo ist sie denn hier, genau
Hey Max ich mache eine Ausbildung zum Physi, kannst du mir was empfehlen das ich lernen
soll vor der Ausbildung?
Interessierst du dich denn, inwieweit interessierst du dich denn für Sachen so im IT Sektor,
was ist denn so das was dich hauptsächlich interessiert?
Leute jetzt fangt man nicht mit Docker Cloud Kubernetes an, man wollte es jetzt mal nicht
übertreiben, es kommt auf den Kenntnisstand an und eine Sache Jung glaubt dem Twitch
und der Twitch Chat mag zwar manchmal Big Brain sein, aber zum kurzem Teil erzählter
Mist.
Also was, Linux Server und sowas, ok das und sowas, das kann ich mir jetzt nix, aber
Linux Server, ja also wenn du dich für Linux und Server interessierst, dann gibt es tatsächlich
ein paar Sachen die du machen kannst die sich an den aktuellen Sachen orientieren die halt
total angesagt sind, also Docker kannst du dir auf jeden Fall mal angucken, ich weiß
nicht inwieweit du dich damit schon auskennst, also ich kann jetzt schlecht sagen wie viele
Sachen du schon mal versucht hast auf dem Linux Server zum laufen zu bringen, ob du
überhaupt schon mal einen Linux Server installiert hast, was du damit gemacht hast, das weiß
ich jetzt nicht, aber wenn du so ein bisschen Ahnung von den Grundkenntnissen hast, also
eine Sache die auf jeden Fall sehr angesagt ist und auch in Zukunft angesagt bleiben
wird, wo ich sogar sagen will, das wird komplett Teil von jeglicher IT Infrastruktur und Entwicklungsprozessen
werden wenn es nicht das schon ist, es ist Docker bzw.
Linux Container, ich würde mir einfach ein paar Docker Webcasts angucken, es gibt super
Docker Tutorials auf YouTube, gehen 3-4 Stunden und erklären dir alles was du wissen musst.
Ja, aber Docker wenn dich Linux interessiert und wenn du auch was Linux mäßiges, wenn
die Firma wo du dann hingehst, auch was Linux mäßiges machst, ist Docker auf jeden Fall
nicht verkehrt und auch in anderen Bereichen, also Docker ist so angesagt und Linux Containern
sind zurzeit so im Trend, da gibt es eigentlich nichts was man falsch machen kann wenn man
sich ein bisschen mit Docker beschäftigt, ansonsten ist das, da hat hier Teys hat Recht,
ansonsten ist das wichtigste dass du dich dafür interessierst, weil man muss ja auch
immer sagen, dass man macht die Ausbildung ja nicht weil man es kann, sondern man macht
die Ausbildung weil man es lernen soll im Endeffekt oder will oder lernen muss, wie
auch immer man das dann sieht, man macht ja nicht alles nur wo man Bock drauf hat und
das wichtigste ist eigentlich sich dafür zu interessieren, das stimmt, das ist richtig.
So, den Rest kannst du vom Chat mal, ist ein kleiner Betrieb mit 6 Mitarbeitern, das kann
gut und schlecht sein, gut ist es, weil du wahrscheinlich von Tag 1 mehr oder weniger
live mitmachen musst, im kleinen Betrieb ist das oftmals so, da ist es nicht so dass
du Azubi mäßig mit irgendeinem Ausbildungsplan und so gedönster sitzt, sondern du wirst
von Tag 1 wahrscheinlich mitmachen müssen, Teys das stimmt nicht, ich war auch wie gesagt
ich hab meine Ausbildung auch bei einem Provider gemacht und wir in Frankfurt waren auch plus
5-6 Leute, die Ausbildung an sich war ausbildungsmäßig so wo man sagen könnte es hat sich mal einer
mit einem hingesetzt und gelernt und was gezeigt war schlecht, ist eigentlich kaum passiert
aber dadurch dass man halt, dass ich halt auch tagtäglich da viel Kram mitgemacht
habe und trotzdem was gelernt, was ist Physi, Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration, aber
Twinkors ist, das kann ja auch was gutes sein, dass du mitmachen musst, also in dem kleinen
Betrieb wird es ziemlich sicher so sein, dass du mitmachen musst, aber wie gesagt
ich fand es ganz gut und du hast den Vorteil, ich weiß ja nicht was die jeweilige Firma
macht und du hast den Vorteil, dass du viele Sachen schon kennenlernst, einfach weil du
nicht drumherum kommst, also sprich zum Beispiel, ich hatte die große Ehre mal vonhanden ein
IBM Playcenter einbauen zu dürfen, es ist jetzt nichts was man unbedingt gemacht haben
muss, das ist jetzt eigentlich eher so, Boomer Max erzählt aus der Kindheit so nach dem Motto
wieder, aber wer so ein Ding schon mal gesehen hat, der weiß das ist schwer, so sehen die
Dinger aus, hat man heute, hat man heute nicht mehr so, En Pachino fragt studiert man sowas
nicht eigentlich, nö, sowas studiert man nicht, ich glaube sowas kann man gar nicht
studieren, ja der Twinkors weiß wovon ich rede, ganz tolle Geschichte, also diese Dinger,
Informatik kann man studieren ja, allerdings geht es da nicht in die Richtung was Fachinformatiker
in Systemintegration oder Anwendungsentwicklung macht, sondern wenn du Informatik studierst
geht es viel um theoretische Sachen, da lernst du zum Beispiel sowas, wie kannst du die Laufzeit
von Algorithmen einschätzen, also in welcher Zeit kann man abschätzen läuft das ganze
durch und solche Sachen lernst du im Informatik Studium zum Beispiel, da lernst du nicht
wenn du Playcenter einbaust, so zumindest noch eine, ah das Bild hier ist schöner vorbei,
eine Runde Boomergeschichte aus meiner Ausbildung, also ihr seht ja dieses Ding, das ist 19 Zoll
Rackbauweise und das funktioniert folgendermaßen, hier sieht man es schön, das ist im Prinzip
eine Gehäuse für Server, also man schiebt, das hier sind die, das hier sind die, das
sind die, eine Gehäuse im Steckkartenformat für Systeme, so das hier sind die einzigen,
die einzelnen Systeme, die kommen da vorne hochkant rein, es gibt auch ein paar, da ist
es horizontal, aber das meiste, also die IBM Dinger sind quasi vertikal und man sieht
es ja auch hier, also die Dinger sind normalerweise auch viel größer, da passen dann 14 Dinger
rein oder sowas, so sieht das Ganze aus, genau, solche Dinger und die waren Schweine teuer
damals, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wir hatten damals Plates, also das hier sind
Plates und das ganze Ding ist ein Plates Center und ich kann mich dran erinnern, wir hatten
die letzten Plates, die wir gekauft haben, hatten damals schon 96 Gigabyte RAM, ich meine
hey 96 Gigabyte RAM ist heute auch noch viel, es ist nicht so, dass 96G heute outdated oder
so wäre, also für die damalige Zeit, das ist ja schon mal 10 Jahre oder so her, also
das ist, wo wir die letzten Plates gekauft haben, also das war schon wirklich ordentlich
Wumms, was du da reinstecken konntest, so und die haben damals glaube ich 12.000 Euro
oder sowas gekostet in Vollbestückung, da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie teuer der
Scheiß war, der da eigentlich reinkommen ist, zumindest irgendjemand bei uns ist mal auf
die glorreiche Idee gekommen, baut mal Plates Center ein und ich sag euch, so ein Ding selbst
leer einzubauen ist wirklich nicht ohne, du hast Schienen, da kannst du dich gefühlt
drauf stellen und es bewegt sich nichts und dann musst du ja noch das quasi so reinheben
in die Schienen, dass es nicht verkantet, das ist auch immer so eine Sache für sich,
also es ist nicht ohne das einzubauen, also ich kenn bloß die Dinger zum reinhängen,
die musst du die da ausziehst und dann hast du dann halt so Klippse, die hängst du rein
und dann macht es dann so und hängt fest, ja und also wie gesagt, ich musste auch schon
ein paar doofe Sachen in der Ausbildung machen oder manchmal halt auch Server ausbauen, am
schlimmsten war es, wenn die, wenn sie es verkackt haben beim Server einbauen und dann
wurde das lustig, wenn du Server ein- beziehungsweise umbauen solltest, die keine Schienen mehr
hatten, dann musstest du ja vorne, wir haben ja vorne Schrauben, so, normalerweise kommen
die auf Schienen drauf, so aber du hast auch ein paar Systeme, die kannst du direkt vorne,
hier sieht man es, die kannst du direkt vorne anschrauben und ja sowas hier, sowas hier
zum Beispiel und wenn du so ein Ding direkt am Rack anschrauben musst, das Ding ist voll
bestückt und du musst das mit einer Hand festhalten und mit der anderen Hand eine Schraube
rein machen, die Schraube irgendwie verkanten, weil du nicht richtig drehen kannst mit einer
Hand, du verkantest dann quasi eine Schraube links unten und verkantest eine Schraube rechts
oben, dass du den zweiten Arm unten drunter raus machen kannst, dass du, in der Hoffnung,
dass es dir nicht runterfällt, weil dann fallen dir halt irgendwie ein 8000 Euro Server runter,
das ist auch nicht so gut, vor allem wenn das irgendwie dann auf Höhen ein, genau, 20
oder so oder 30 eingebaut wird und also Taze mir ist noch nicht ein Server runtergefallen
in der ganzen Ausbildung und sieht fast aus wie Mein Rack ein bisschen, zumindest das geht
wirklich auf den Arm, das geht echt auf den Arm, sondern schreibst du die eine Seite
rein, die andere Seite rein, dann kannst du festschrauben, ja es gab schon, es gab schon
echt ein paar abenteuerliche Sachen, am besten war es noch, wo sie uns in der Ausbildung,
den Felix und mich, den Felix kennt vielleicht noch, welchen von YouTube, mit dem hab ich
ja von der Gamescom Video gemacht, der hat ja mit mir zusammen die Ausbildung gemacht,
der kam glaube ich eins oder zwei Jahre später nach mir und damals haben sie den Felix und
mich zusammen in die Netzwerksschränke geschickt, weil wir die dünnsten waren und da durchgepasst
haben, die hatten nämlich die glorreiche Idee damals die Switche quasi nicht in den Rack,
in die Netzwerksschränke, also in die Netzwerkräume, in die Netzwerkräume, nicht die Switche
in den Rack, Horizont, also übereinander zu machen, sondern die Switche bei uns hingen
in den Technikräumen, weil die so klein waren, hingen die verkehrt rum, also mit der Front
nach oben, die hingen da so quasi an so einem Stück Metall und da musste man entweder dran
vorbei oder unten drunter durchkrabbeln und da haben sie damals gesagt, okay Max, Felix
oder Felix Max, könnt ihr das mal machen, wir passen da nicht durch und da könnt ihr
euch vorstellen Leute, dass ich schon lange her, wenn die zu mir gesagt haben, ich bin
der dünnste und pass da durch, das war 2007 oder so, ja, aber ich sehe es im Chat, ein
paar von euch kennen das auch, aber das sind ordentliche Racks, das ist auch halbwegs ordentlich
Racks, man muss ja sagen, dass mittlerweile, es gibt ja mittlerweile viele Firmen, die
quasi sagen, sie kümmern sich um das Rechenzentrum Management für ein, wenn die das machen,
also wir haben also eine Firma, die sich bei uns quasi um das Ein- und Ausbau und Verkabel
und sowas kümmert, dann sieht es halbwegs ordentlich aus und das hier sieht auch noch
halbwegs ordentlich aus, aber ohne Scheiß Leute, unser damaligen Patch-Panels, die sahen
nicht so aus, die sahen eher, die sahen eher so aus und noch viel voller als die, noch
viel voller, ja so, ohne Scheiß, so wie das hier links auf dem Bild, so wie das hier links
auf dem Bild aussah, war es an unserem Core-Switch-Schrank und es war jedes Mal ein Abenteuer, Sachen
zu patchen bzw. abzustöpseln, umzustöpseln, weil du jedes Mal Angst haben musst, du ziehst
das falsche System raus, ungefähr so sah das an unserem Core-Switch-Schrank aus, wie
das linke hier, na gut, so schlimm ist es auch nicht gewesen, aber ungefähr wie das
linke, was ich euch eben gezeigt habe und das schlimmste, ich weiß, es ist wieder absolut
Boomer-Storytime angesagt und das schlimmste war, wo hatte ich denn eben das Bild mit dem
geilen Cable-Management, hier, und das schlimmste bei uns war, dass in dem gleichen Schrank
nicht nur normale Netzwerkverkabelung drin war, sondern auch Glasfaserverkabelung für
Sahngeschichten, wo hast du deine Ausbildung gemacht, wie gesagt, ich sag nur bei einem
Server-Provider, ich sag nicht bei welchen, da war noch Glasfaserverkabelung drin, ich
sag euch, das war eklig, das war richtig eklig, war das ein Server-Provider oder ein ESP,
beides, die haben beides im Programm, die haben beides im Programm.
Dementsprechend hat man aber ein bisschen was gelernt, also so schlecht war das gar nicht.
So, was hab ich im Chat übersehen?
Ganz viel.
Welcher ESP bietet den Server an?
Tja.
Du musst nicht weit gucken, guck mal zur Telekom, die haben auch die Magenta-Cloud.
Hallo, Chat, ich will scrollen.
Was, meine Firma macht ein Online-Demos, hat nur vier Monate gedauert, die Kamera aufzustellen.
Ah, exzellent.
Bob, Bob's Group.
Das am Anfang ist ein bisschen aus wie Movie Maker, aber wahrscheinlich ist es eher Final-Cut-Vorlage
oder so.
Oh.
Was ist denn das?
Ist aus wie ein Röntgenbild, was ist das?
Ich würde sagen 3D-Drucker in groß, aber ist es wahrscheinlich.
Textilprinter.
Ja, Big Brain, die Move, Move, nicht Movement, Move, Moveent-A.G.
So, ich hab wie gesagt jede Menge Sachen wahrscheinlich übersehen.
Wir haben damals bei laufendem Betrieb den Schrank gewächst, oh, so Dinge haben wir auch
schon getrieben, ja, ja, das ist ganz toll, ganz, ganz toll.
Wubblos in 20, so sieht's aus, ja, ja, Pepe Fett.
So viel hab ich gar nicht übersehen.
Hast du dir schon mal die Fortbildung der IHK angeschaut?
Gibt ja zum Beispiel sowas wie ein IT-Operate, was?
Der ist im deutschen Qualifikationsrahmen gleichzustellen wie ein Bachelor, sowas kann
man bedarf...
Was?
Ein IT-Operative.
Klingt nach irgendeiner IHK-Sache, damit sie relevant bleiben.
Was ist denn ein IT-Operative?
Ja, Operative Profession, da hat sich die IHK wieder irgendwas ausgedacht.
IT-Systems Manager.
Ah, hier, da hat sich die IHK wieder für das Zeug ausgedacht.
Sie entwickeln, Moment, ich muss mal kurz den Dark Reader rausmachen.
Das ist doch sowas, was keiner macht, oder?
Das macht doch keiner.
Das haben fünf Leute abgeschlossen, insgesamt, seit es das gibt, wahrscheinlich.
Geprüfter IT-Entwickler.
Alter, die IHK, was ist mit denen los?
Okay, also zugelassen ist abgeschlossene Ausbildung eines IHK.
Ja, da hab ich, ja.
ISO, was?
Das ist sowas, was, glaube ich, kein Mensch braucht, oder?
Es gibt auch staatlich anerkannte Informatiker, zählt so viel wie ein Masterstudium.
Das glaub ich persönlich nicht, dass das so viel zählt.
Also, wenn jemand schreibt in sein Stellenprofil, er hätte jemand gerne Masteranschluss, da
musste wahrscheinlich nicht mit Operative Professional ankommen oder mit anerkanntem
geprüften Informatiker oder sowas.
Wenn einer einen Masterabschluss haben will, dann will der einen Masterabschluss haben.
Du lernst doch auch ganz andere Sachen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich in der Wunschwelt der IHK so, dass das ein Masterstand ist, aber
ist es nicht.
Ja, äh, Patrick sah zuerst aus wie als Druck der Geldscheine.
Monkratos.
Habt ihr beim Steam Sale zugeschaltet?
Nee, ich wollte gerade gucken, was es da gibt.
Äh, jede Menge CSGO, Scam-Arts-Geschichten.
Hallo, gibt's da auch was Gescheites?
Ich will nicht den Point, ich will den Summer Sale haben.
Was ist denn die Seite vom Summer Sale?
Team, das wird doch immer beworben.
Hier, Summer Sale, warum kriege ich da irgendwelche CSGO-Sachen beworben?
Äh, ja, äh, was ich jetzt gerade gesehen habe noch, äh, jung so Bücher bringen es
nicht.
Das ist komplett verschwendeter Zeit.
Ah, Points Shop, das ist extra, da waren wir doch vorhin richtig.
Oh, ja, Max Pan Franchise, was haben die da für welche?
Alle.
Moment, wo ist der erste?
Gut, ich meine, den ersten kannst du hier bei GOG für 50 Cent oder so kaufen.
Irgendwie ist es voll langweilig, was es da gibt, es ist nix dabei.
Ich will keine Top Seller, ich will wissen, was im Angebot ist, es ist nix dabei.
Oh, nee, also wer eine absolut cringige, japanisch angehauchte Cringe Story haben will, der muss
sich Ace Combat 7 geben.
Das ist teilweise so krass zum Fremdschämen, die Story, da konnte ich nicht mehr zugucken.
Ich habe fast alle Ace Combat Spiele außer die ersten auf der PS1 gespielt und ich finde
die Serie auch ziemlich gut, aber die Story ist so hardcore cringig an manchen Stellen.
Oh, nee, da gibt es zum Beispiel eine Szene, ohne zu sehr zu spoilern, wo die Charaktere
einfach total dumm sind, also es gibt in diesem Spiel einen riesen Turm quasi mal, ohne zu
sehr zu spoilern, es gibt einen riesen Turm und ein Charakter in der Story ist der Meinung,
anstatt die Treppe runter zu laufen, wohlgemerkt, um diesen Turm fliegen gerade Flugzeuge rum
und schießen sich gegenseitig ab.
So, und dieser Charakter ist, ich sag jetzt im 70.
Stock, und dieser Charakter denkt sich, anstatt die Treppe zu nehmen, springe ich jetzt einfach
mit meinem Fallschirm aus dem 70. Stockwerk ab, obwohl gerade um mich drum herum ganz
viele Flugzeuge explodieren und was passiert, was passiert, fliegt ein Flugzeug dagegen.
Die Story ist so fail, ist so fail, dass es weh tut.
Wallpaper Engine, ja gut, wenn ich auch möchte, dass meine Grafikkarte schön ausgelastet ist,
während ich nichts mache, dann könnte ich das tun, ja.
Allerdings hat es extrem gute Bewertungen.
Ich sehe den Sinn da drin nicht, aber, how to install wallpapers, bad, 10 Stunden, krass,
das heißt, er hat 10 Stunden jetzt gesucht, wie man Wallpapers installiert oder was, big
brain, manchmal frage ich mich auch, was ist mit den Leuten los, das ist, was heißt,
das ist nice, das ist eher low brain. Journey gibt es jetzt für den PC, was, seit wann
denn das, seit wann gibt es Journey für den PC, MonkaS, ah, seit, seit elften, das spielen
wir nochmal im Stream, das geht ganz schnell, das Game geht bloß glaube ich eine Stunde
oder so, das spielen wir nochmal, das ist eines der besten Spiele, nicht wirklich, Spiel
ist es nicht, das ist eines der besten, nennen wir es mal Kunstprojekte, die es gibt in Spielform.
Experience, genau, ach guck mal, Flower gibt es auch, wobei Journey war das beste, was
wir gemacht haben.
Es ist eine Experience mit etwas Interaktion, genau, also Audio, visuell und gerade halt,
das kann ich jetzt nicht erzählen, weil dann ist das Spiel langweilig, gerade auch die
Interaktion zwischen den, das ist ja so etwas Multiplayer, aber nicht wirklich, so bisschen
Multiplayer, ist eines der besten Sachen, die ich je gespielt habe unterm Strich. Das
Spiel ist genau das, was es sein soll, was sich viele Spiele schaffen, viele wollen da
mehr als sie dann letztendlich sind, aber die haben genau das geschafft zu sein, was
sie wollen. Also wer es noch nicht hat, sollte das wirklich unbedingt mal spielen. Man kann
sagen, gut 10 Euro für 2 Stunden Spielzeit, vielleicht ein bisschen viel, aber ich kann
euch sagen, wenn ihr Journey gespielt habt, das ist ein Spiel, das vergesst ihr nicht,
das werdet ihr nie vergessen. Ich kann mich heute noch dran erinnern, an meinen PS3 Playthrough.
Far Cry 5, ne bloß nicht, da mach ich einen Bogen drum, Far Cry 3 beste, Dishonored kann
man sich geben, das ist immer ganz gut. Rainbow Six, da muss ich ja sagen, eine der Fälle,
wo ich mich mal echt komplett geirrt hab, ich hab am Anfang gesagt, Rainbow Six, der
Start war auch verkackt, da muss man ja zu guter, der Start war auch verkackt, wo ich
gesagt hab, das wird im Leben nix nach dem Start, aber Ubisoft hat sich Mühe gegeben.
Browse More, Visual Novels, ist da Sebaro noch da, das war es für dich. Habt ihr schon
den Chair Sex Simulator gesehen? Moment, ich muss das auf Steam suchen, sonst ist das
Monka Toss. Habt ihr schon den Chair Fucking Simulator gesehen? Das meinen die ernst. Der
Chair Fucking Simulator, das kommt raus, wenn Steam jeden Scheiß zulässt, erscheint angeblich
in 5 Tagen. Das ist der Chair Fucking Simulator. Was sagt eigentlich die Diskussionspage?
What if I prefer tables? This is why Aliens won't visit us. Ja, jetzt habt ihr auch mal
gesehen den Chair Fucking Simulator. Komplett safe for work, weil er kennt nix, außer dass
Chairs gefackt werden. Was ist das für ne Kulisse hier dabei? Und was soll das hier
für ein komisches Ding sein? Also Steam macht nicht gerade Werbung für sich mit solchen
Games. Ich mein in dem Fall ist klar, das ist ein Gag, aber trotzdem, es gibt so viel
Bullshit auf Steam. So, was wird denn sonst so angeboten? Irgendwie finde ich die Steamsachen
immer Hardcore unübersichtlich. Ich möchte einfach eine Seite haben, wo ich alles Sales
und Gebote durchscrollen kann. Ach, das gibt es jetzt auch für den PC. Kann man nicht
hier einfach sagen, ne? Wie kann ich einfach sagen, ich möchte alles mal sehen. Oh, Titanfall,
ja das kann ich auch wirklich jedem ans Herz legen, der es noch nicht gespielt hat. Gar
nicht so sehr wegen dem Multiplayer, sondern die Kampagne ist die beste Singleplayer Baller-Shooter-Kampagne
der letzten Jahre. Und wenn es nur für den Singleplayer ist, holt euch Titanfall 2. Ihr
werdet kaum bessere Singleplayer finden, wo man auch mal was machen kann neben Cutscenes
gucken. Für 9,89€, da kann man wirklich nix falsch machen. Den ganzen anderen Krempel
braucht ihr nicht, wenn ihr kein Multiplayer spielen wollt. Die Kampagne ist nice. Also
ich hab die Call of Duty Kampagne mittlerweile übrigens fertig gespielt und ich muss sagen,
es war ganz okay. Also das letzte Drittel ist ziemlich gut, der Schluss ist nicht so
toll, aber das erste Drittel der Call of Duty Kampagne fand ich kacke. Total zusammenhangloses
Zeug. So, das nächste Drittel wurde schon besser, man hat auch ein bisschen was erklärt
bekommen. Das letzte Drittel war ziemlich gut, dadurch, dass man eben auch mal erklärt
bekommen hat in der Kampagne, woher die sich eigentlich alle kennen. Das war irgendwie
ein bisschen falsch, ein bisschen verkehrt herum. Die erzählen dir die ganze Kampagne,
die tun so, als würden sie sich kennen und du denkst dir, woher kennen die sich und am
Ende erfährt man dann auch mal, woher die sich kennen. Ja, okay, das ergibt Sinn. Auch
ein super Game, wer es noch nicht gespielt hat. Also wer beispielsweise auf ein neues
Baldur's Gate gehofft hat, ist das das nächste Spiel, was ihr spielen könnt, weil das sind
die gleichen Leute, die sich jetzt auch um Baldur's Gate 3 kümmern. Und wer das, wer
Originals Sin 2 gespielt hat und wer sich mal den neuen Baldur's Gate 3 Trailer angeguckt
hat, der wird schon auffällig viele Parallelen finden, so wie die Welt aussieht. Auch das
mit den Effekten auf dem Boden und so, da ist schon, ist schon ganz schön viel. So wie
komme ich denn jetzt einfach? So, wie komme ich in Steam Special Offer? Wie kriege ich
das in Steam hin, dass ich einfach mal alle Sachen mir angezeigt bekomme, die im Sales
sind? Das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein. Weg. Special Offers. What? Ich habe das gestern
versucht zu testen, aber ich konnte es nicht testen. Ich konnte es nicht testen, weil Microsoft
entweder mich von Hand freischalten möchte, ich Lizenzschlüssel brauche und Microsoft
halt, wenn ich keine Firma bin, mit denen ich gibt. Also keine Chance. So, gibt es denn
sonst noch irgendwelche Sachen, die sie hier noch nicht empfohlen haben? Seymour Specials.
Okay. Ah, hier. Jetzt kriegt man angezeigt, was alles noch günstiger ist. So, das ist
nämlich alles. Okay. Ne, 10 Euro. Ich hadere ja immer noch mit mir, ob es sich lohnt, dafür
eine 3D-Brille zu kaufen. Ihr wisst, ich bin riesengroßer Half-Life-Fan. Was kostet der
Lizenzschlüssel? Das gibt es nicht so einzeln. Man braucht irgendeine Microsoft Lizenz-Server-Geschichte,
wo dann der Windows Defender Teil von ist. Fragt mich nicht. Ich habe es mir nicht genau
angeguckt. War unnötig, Microsoft-Style-mäßig kompliziert. Ich bin zwar riesengroßer Half-Life-Fan,
aber ich will mir keine 3D-Brille kaufen für ein Spiel, was ich sonst... Ich meine, eine
ordentliche 3D-Brille wirst du auch mindestens 500, 600 Euro ausgeben müssen. Und wenn es
ja mehr Sachen gäbe dafür, das wäre ja cool. Aber aktuell habe ich halt nur das, was ich
spielen will. Ich weiß, der Chat kommt jetzt gleich an und sagt, Max, guck doch, guck doch
VR-Porn. Aber an Spielen, ich will eigentlich nur das spielen als in 3D. Oder in VR. VR,
meine ich ja. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was der Lizenzschlüssel kostet. Oh nein, für VR-Porn
kaufe ich mir keine Brille. Wenn ich mir eine Brille kaufe, dann hier dafür. Aber das ist
es nicht wert, für ein Spiel sich 500, 600 Euro auszugeben. Außerdem wüsste ich gar
nicht, welche VR-Brille sich aktuell lohnt. Was weiß das jemand von euch? Nutzt du noch
viel an Shield TV auch zum Spielen? Das Shield TV ist jeden Tag, jeden Abend mehrere Stunden
im Einsatz, funktioniert wunderbar. Zum Spielen sehr selten. Dieser Titanfall 2 kann ich jedem
empfehlen. Die Master Chief Collection ist sagenhafte 7 Euro runter gesetzt. Was ist
da eigentlich alles mittlerweile dabei? Halo 1, Halo 2, Halo 3, Halo 4, Halo Reach, nee,
Moment, not available, not available. Moment, das ist alles gar nicht dabei. Das ist alles
gar nicht dabei. Rest kommt erst. Aber gibt es das nicht schon für die Xbox komplett?
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Also aktuell gibt es da nur was? Halo 1? Ja, aber das ist doch
nicht remastered oder ist das remastered? Ja, ein bisschen remastered könnte das sein,
aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist doch nicht remastered. Das sieht genauso aus wie das originale Halo.
Oder habe ich das originale Halo hübscher in Erinnerung als es eigentlich war? Das ist
doch das originale Halo. Ist doch nicht remastered. Okay, vielleicht habe ich Halo hübscher in
Erinnerung als es eigentlich ist. Ich meine, es war für seine Zeit eines der hübschesten
Games überhaupt. So den großen Unterschied erkenne ich. Naja, okay. Ein bisschen vielleicht.
Was gibt es sonst noch? Halo 2 und Reach. Dann lohnt sich die Master Chief Collection
noch nicht für drei Games. So, was gibt es denn sonst noch? Terraria. Das ist auch so
ein Game, das hält sich auch schon 5-6 Jahre. Red Dead Redemption 2. Ich muss ja sagen,
ich habe weder eins noch zwei gespielt und alle tun immer so, als hätte ich wahnsinnig
was verpasst. Aber ich habe absolut kein Interesse Red Dead Redemption 2 zu spielen. Beide Games
sind echt gut. Weder juckt mich das Western-Szenario noch mag ich großartig Open World Games. Deswegen
habe ich da eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Mountain Plate 2. Das ist was für
die Mittelalterstelse unter uns. Skyrim. Alter, ist es euer Ernst, dass Skyrim immer noch
so viel, das Spiel ist 10 Jahre alt oder so? Warum ist denn Skyrim immer noch so, na gut,
es verkauft sich halt, ne? Ich hätte gedacht, Skyrim gibt es für 1,50 oder so. Aber es
verkauft sich halt, warum sollte man es billiger machen? Das habe ich letztens im Stream gesehen,
das sah eigentlich ganz gut aus. Das ist so ein Weltraum-Abbau-Stell. Keine Ahnung, wie
man es genau beschreiben soll. Das sah eigentlich ganz cool aus. Gibt es eigentlich irgendeine
Plattform außer meinem Taschenrechner, wo es kein Skyrim drauf gibt? Skyrim gibt es
doch mittlerweile echt für alles. Battlefront 2. Oh, very positives sind wir jetzt mittlerweile.
Moment, welches Battlefront 2 ist das denn überhaupt? Okay, das aktuelle. Nicht das
von 2005. Mal wieder der Switcher am Start. Wer es noch nicht hat, kann man sich bedenkenlos
zu kaufen. Also eins muss man ja auch noch mal über Witcher 3 sagen. Also, noch meistens
sind DLCs nicht so das. Aber der Heart of Stone DLC für Witcher 3 ist das beste am
ganzen Spiel. Ark hat mich noch nie großartig interessiert. Wir haben jemand auf der Arbeit,
der spielt Ark auf der PS4. Und ich habe schon von ein paar Leuten gehört, dass wenn der
Nachtschicht hat, also ich muss keine Nachtschicht machen, aber wir haben bei uns ein Team, das
ist 247 da und hat ein Auge auf das System. Und wenn der Nachtschicht hat, habe ich schon
von ein paar Leuten gehört, unabhängig voneinander, dass der manchmal seine PS4 mitnimmt und dann
nachts im Büro sitzt und PS4 Ark Multiplayer spielt und sogar im Voicecom seine Mitspieler
flamet. Und das ging mal seinen zwei Mitschicht-Kollegen so sehr auf den Sack, dass sie eben die PS4
ausgeschaltet haben. Also ich meine, das ist schon auf mehreren Ebenen dreist. Also erst
ist die PS4 mit auf die Arbeit zu nehmen. Danach Multiplayer-Headset und sonst was zu
spielen, aber danach auch noch Voice-Chat-Multiplayer zu spielen. Wenn das der Chef hört, also der
Chef von ihm guckt hier garantiert nicht zu. Der einzige Chef, wo irgendwie nur ansatzweise
die Möglichkeit bestehen würde, der hier zuguckt, ist vielleicht meiner, glaube ich
aber nicht, aber der Chef von ihm guckt hier garantiert nicht zu. GTA hätten die auch
nie mit gerechnet, dass das so ein Riesenerfolg online wird. Rust ist auch so ein Ding, dass
es immer noch am Start ist, ey. Der Football-Manager 2020. Alter wie sieht das denn aus, Igitt?
Moment. Habt ihr das Spielfeld gesehen? Das sieht aus wie FIFA N64. Was ist denn das?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen? Was ist das denn für eine Grafik? Das sah FIFA auf dem N64
schöner aus. Outer Wilds, das soll ganz gut sein. Das ist so ein bisschen Jump'n Run mäßig,
das soll ganz gut sein. Oma, ist das das überhaupt? Das ist das ziemlich sicher, jaja, das ist
ähm, ja wo man dann rumjumpt. Das soll ganz okay sein. Warum gibt es eigentlich so unglaublich
viele Survival Games? Es gibt Millionen von Survival Games und eins sieht genauso aus
wie das andere. Monster, der juckt mich nicht. Ich auch nicht. Ähm, ich wirklich. Das ist
auch so ein richtig olles Ding. Dark Souls Dead by Daylight. Gibt es da nicht schon Teil
2 jetzt? Oder bringe ich das durcheinander? Ach nee, das ist das mit dem Mörder, wo man
flüchten muss. Ähm, das meine ich gar nicht. Aber wie heißt dieses andere Zombie-Game,
wo es jetzt einen zweiten Teil gibt? Das heißt doch auch irgendwie, wie ist das denn? Das
dieses Jump'n Run Parkour-Zombie-Ding, wo es jetzt auch einen zweiten Teil von gibt. Nicht
The Last of Us. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Dying Light, Dying Light. Ich wusste, ey komm, Dead
by Daylight und Dying Light, das kann man schon mal verwechseln, wenn man beides nicht gespielt
hat. Dead Island, oder Dead Island. Vielleicht hat es ja auch was mit Island zu tun. Fuck.
Hab ich in dem Friseur mal gespielt ein bisschen, fand ich echt langweilig. War das, ich muss
mal kurz gucken, ob das auch wahr war, was ich jetzt hier erzähle. Ja. Dann haben wir
sogar mal was hochgeladen. Boah, dann haben wir sogar mal was hochgeladen, wo wir zusammen
gespielt haben. Heavy Rain. Warum sind denn die ganzen PS4-Dinger und PS3-Dinger, PS3-Dinger
in dem Fall, dann jetzt auf einmal alle auf dem PC. Wollen die doch ein paar Verkaufszahlen
abgreifen. Black Mesa 1.0. Ja, wer es noch nicht hat, kaufen. Heavy Rain ist mir persönlich
das immer noch das Lieblingsgame von denen. Vielleicht, weil es was Neues war, das erste,
was ich gespielt habe und von der ganzen Sache am interessantesten finde. So, was haben wir
dann sonst noch? Der Euro Truck Simulator. Das ist auch so ein Game, wo glaube ich der
DLC hunderte Euro kostet, bis man da alles hat. Prison Architect habe ich mir gekauft,
habe ich noch nicht gespielt. Rimworld habe ich mir auch mal irgendwann gekauft, noch nicht
gespielt. Stardew Valley habe ich mir auch mal irgendwann gekauft, noch nicht gespielt.
Den zweiten Teil wollte ich mal spielen, wobei die Ori Story dann wieder hier. Pepehands.
Ich weiß aber schon, wie es ausgeht. Ich habe schon den Abspann gesehen, ich weiß, was
passiert. Wobei so richtig sad, egal, ich sag nix. Eigentlich ist es ja gar nicht so,
aber doch irgendwo schon. Dates gibt es das immer noch. Dates. Was mache ich? Warz. Warz
gibt es ja nicht mehr. Warz heißt jetzt Survivor Stories. Mal gucken, wie da die Bewertungen
sind. Ach, Dead Rising haben wir gezockt. Dann bringe ich es durcheinander. Okay, die
Bewertungen sind immer noch schlecht. Dates. Das ist auch nie fertig geworden, das Game.
Also, bevor Battle Royale im Hype war, war ja mal eine Zeitlang Zombie Survival im Hype.
Unter anderem Dates. Und ich glaube, seitdem hat sich an dem Game nie was getan. Die sind
ein bisschen kaputt, würde ich sagen, gerade die Bewertung auf Steam. Was kostet es denn?
Ganz schön teuer für ein unfertiges Kack Game. Wo die Laufanimation immer noch so aussehen,
als hätte nie einer eine ordentliche L- Guckt euch mal die Laufanimation an. Was ist denn
mit denen los, dass die sich überhaupt trauen, da mit einem Trailer zu machen? Das sieht
aus, als hätte er in die Hose geschissen. Habt ihr das gerade gesehen? Oh Mann, der hat
was in der Hose. Siehst du sofort. Oh ja, ich muss mal wohin. Schnell. Also, das ist
immer noch komplett unfertiger Crap. Metro Exodus wollte ich mir kaufen, bin ja nicht
zugekommen es zu spielen. Also, gekauft habe ich mir noch nicht, aber das will ich auch
auf jeden Fall nochmal spielen. Destiny 2, gut, das ist ein bisschen an mir vorbeigegangen.
Dragon Quest Builders 2 habe ich nicht gespielt, auch das erste nicht, aber ich habe Dance
Game ein bisschen das Let's Play geguckt und es sah wirklich ganz spaßig aus. Garry's
Mod habe ich mir schon vor Jahren gekauft. Habe ich mir auch gekauft, noch nicht gespielt.
Warum habe ich eigentlich so viele Games? Habe ich auch gekauft, nicht wirklich gespielt.
Interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Die haben alle geschwärmt. Bestes RPG des Jahres und
sonst war es irgendwie spricht es mir nicht an. Was ist das? Das kenne ich nicht. Sieht
RPG mäßig aus. Habe ich mir gekauft, war drei Tage ganz nett. Danach habe ich rausgekriegt,
was die OP Kombi ist und hatte ich keinen Bock mehr, aber vielleicht ist es mittlerweile
viel besser. Das sieht unfertig aus. Das sieht nachher absolut fake Diablo aus. Alter Lul,
was ist denn das? Ach, Early Access, okay, Grip, gleich weg. Early Access Games werden
aus Prinzip nicht mehr gekauft. Ich gehe, sorry, ich gehe in eine Viertelstunde. Gehe
ich pennen. Okay, Steam ist vor allem abkacken gerade. Guckt es euch an. Lädt überhaupt
nicht mehr. Hallo, Steam. Grip. Resident Evil 2 wollte ich mir mal holen, das Remake. Das
soll ja ziemlich gut sein. Was sie in Resident Evil 3 mit Jill gemacht haben, weiß ich nicht.
Die sieht irgendwie unterernährt aus. Richte ich das mal an. Auf dem Bild sieht man es
nicht so richtig. Die sieht eher aus, als müsste man was essen, anstatt Zombies zu bekämpfen.
Also irgendwie sieht Jill in dem Teil echt unterernährt aus. Muss ja nicht jeder Pepofett
sein. Aber was da los ist. Transport Fever. Ah ja. Es gibt immer noch Terminator Lizenz
Games. Es ist ja nicht nur, als wären die letzten Filme alle trash gewesen, nein. Wahrscheinlich
sind die letzten Spiele auch alle trash. Hast du Red Dead Redemption 2 gespielt? Nein. Oh
ja. Wer es noch nicht hat, spielen. Eines der besten Games ever. Das erste. Das zweite
muss man nicht spielen. Das erste. Bioshock. Das ist richtig gut. Gears Tactics. Soll ganz
gut sein, hat mich überrascht, aber ist nicht meins. Habe ich mir gekauft, auch noch nicht
gespielt? Äh ne, sorry, nicht Origins. Odyssey habe ich mir gekauft. Habe ich auch noch nicht
gespielt? Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht. Der Farming Simulator der Far Cry 5 juckt mich
auch nicht. Und Bioshock Infinite. Ja, ist auch ganz gut gewesen. Also was bei Bioshock
Infinite richtig gut war, war der eine NPC, der die ganze Zeit bei einem ist oder der
drei Viertel des Games bei einem ist. Und das war, wenn nicht sogar das erste Mal in
so einem Game, dass sie es geschafft haben, einen NPC einzubauen, der permanent dabei
ist und nicht nervt. Das ist echt ein großer Verdienst. Ansonsten fand ich Infinite nicht
so gut wie Bioshock 1. Die Auflösung am Ende von Infinite war irgendwie zu big brain für
mich. Wer es gespielt hat, weiß vielleicht, was ich meine, aber die war zu weit gedacht
finde ich. So, ne, muss nicht unbedingt sein. Dead Space 3 muss auch nicht sein. Muss auch
nicht sein. Warum gibt es den Gordon Freeman Skin in dem Final Fantasy Game? Mehr Out of
Place könnte doch was gar nicht sein. Ich meine, ohne Scheiß, Leute, wo wirkt denn
bitte schön, denn Gordon Freeman's Skin ist mehr Out of Place als in dem Final Fantasy
Game. Äh, ne. In Fifa. Richtig. Wobei, ne, sogar in Fifa wird er passender finden als
in so einem Japan RPG. No Man's Sky soll mittlerweile richtig gut sein. Hören sagen.
Kann ich auch nur empfehlen, wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, für mich das beste Klassik-RPG
der letzten Jahre. Obwohl das so geflamed wurde von vielen, aber es ist richtig gut.
Das passiert mir nicht. Hab ich schon durchgespielt? Fand ich gar nicht schlecht. Es ist halt relativ
wenig Game. Es ist ein bisschen Hack and Slay mit fünf verschiedenen Angriffen. Sinnlose
Puzzles. Die Story ist ganz gut. Wenn auch ziemlich abgedreht. Aber sowohl das Voice-Acting
als auch die Animationen und von der Atmosphäre fand ich das echt gut. Und nachdem ich ja
eh auf so ein bisschen nordische Mythologie und so stehe, fand ich das super. Das Ende
war auch wieder Next Level Big Brain. Massive. Funktioniert das mittlerweile? Das war ja
so ein verbackter Haufen Kacke, als es rausgekommen ist. Da gab es ja die ganzen Meme-Videos
auf YouTube, wo die Augen gerendert wurden, aber das Gesicht nicht und wo die Leute teilweise
rückwärts gelaufen sind, aber vorwärts und sowas. Was ist das? Keine Ahnung. Moment,
es gibt einen X4? Muss ich gar nicht. Und gab es denn das? Ah, es sackt. Okay, das hatten
wir ja quasi schon. Spielt lieber den zweiten Teil, das ist in allen Belangen besser. Wobei
der erste auch nicht schlecht war. Hollow Knight, nice Game. Ich habe nur mal ganz kurz
angefangen zu spielen, habe ich mir schon vor einer ganzen Weile gekauft, aber macht
einen richtig guten Eindruck. Hast du schon von der 25-Billionen-Klage gegen Twitch und
Streamerinnen gelesen, weil wegen zu sexy? Hä? Nee. Was? Sebaro kann ich das aufmachen
ohne Toss. Okay, was? Hä? Twitch zu sexy? Kläger will 25 Millionen
wegen anzüglicher Streamerinnen. Äh, wat? Ey, könne sich den anzüglichen Streamerinnen
nicht entziehen. Mit dieser, naja gut. Ey, ganz so weit hergeholt ist dieser Satz zumindest
nicht. Also manchmal denkst du auf Twitch, okay, was ist hier los? Du scrollst durch
und denkst dir, okay, Boobcam, Boobcam, Boobcam. Mit dieser Begründung erhebt ein Mann aus
Kalifornien Klage gegen Twitch. Erfordert 25 Millionen US-Dollar Schadensersatz. Äh,
okay, das ist jetzt echt weit hergeholt. Die beuten ihn doch nicht aus. Oder kann er
nicht wieder stehen, wenn er das sieht und muss dann donaten oder was? Habt ihr das mitgekriegt
von dem Typ, der Ninja immer, oder war das Ninja? Ah nee, war das Ninja? Irgendein Typ,
gab es mal, ich glaube der hat Ninja immer donatet oder auch anderen größeren Streamern
und man dachte, boah, der Typ ist ultra reich und am Ende ist rausgekommen, der war donationsüchtig,
der hat seinen Job verloren. Vorher hat er gut verdient und konnte sich die donations
leisten, aber der hat seinen Job verloren, der war bei irgendeinem Autohersteller und
der hat immer weiter donatet, auch nachdem er seinen Job verloren hat, weil er gesagt
hat, es hat ihm Anerkennung in der Community gebracht und er fand auch das Image, dass
er quasi, ähm, da als reich, da steht gut und er hat sich komplett pleite donatet und
am Ende hat er eine GoFoundMe Kampagne gestartet für 10.000 Dollar Krankenhausaufenthalt. Wie
hieß denn der Typ? A fake donation, nee, nach was suche ich denn da jetzt am besten? Donation,
Twitch, pleite, ähm, fake rich, nach was suche ich denn da jetzt? Wie hieß der Typ
denn? Das hat doch bestimmt einer von euch mitgekriegt, ähm, was heißt, was heißt,
was heißt ein pleite auf Englisch? Bankrupt oder so? Broke. Wie hieß denn der Typ noch
mal? Der Sebaro hat es wieder gefunden hier. Ich glaube den meine ich, AC Royal, genau
den meine ich. Den meine ich, genau. Der hat sein komplettes Erspartes donatet auf Twitch,
ähm, und dann war er pleite und hat eine GoFoundMe Kampagne gestartet für sein Krankenhausaufenthalt.
Das meine ich, genau. Ist schon, ist schon zwei Jahre her. Drei Jahre. Also der Typ,
man kann donationsüchtig sein. Okay, aber das ist ja natürlich, das ist jetzt ja komplett,
äh, also komplett aus den Fingern gesaugt, ja. Wen hat er dann schon verklagt? Er hat
schon Microsoft, Sony, Nintendo und Blizzard verklagt. Hat er nichts anderes zu tun? Hat
er zu viel Geld? Medizinischer Probleme dazu gezwungen das Haus nicht zu verlassen und
deshalb für das Internet als Quelle zur Unterhaltung beschränkt. Ja, damit können wir uns ja alle
internifizieren. Außerdem leidet er an Zwangsstörungen und einer Sexsucht. Ja, dann kann er Twitch
nichts dafür. Dann soll er sich, dann soll er sich halt auf irgendwelchen Seiten Mädels
bestellen. Aber das hat auch mit Twitch nichts zu tun. Gibt genug Seiten wo man Mädels bestellen
kann, die kommen auch heim. Und dann kann er, kann er sich, kann er sich ausleben. Das
hat auch mit Twitch nichts zu tun. All diese Faktoren hätte Twitch durch die Art, wie das
Netzwerk von anzüglichen Inhalten bietet, deutlich verschlimmert. Twitch hat seinen
Zustand extrem verschärft. Ja, aber selbst, selbst wenn das so sein sollte, was für ein
Schaden ist ihm denn dadurch entstanden? Twitch ist sogar günstig in dem Moment. Es
ist ja ein Unterschied, ja. Bei Twitch kann er sich das halt nur angucken und das war's.
Aber wenn er, wie gesagt, sexsüchtig ist, da interpretiere ich jetzt mal rein, dass
der halt in echt ran will, dann bringt Twitch zu ihm, guckt nichts. Kann er mal bei Katja
Krasavice anrufen? Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen, komplett random, wurde mir das vorgeschlagen,
Interview mit Katja Krasavice, Krashavice. Ich weiß nicht, wie man sie genau ausspricht.
Die sieht komplett anders aus jetzt, so als hätte sie fünf Schönheits-OPs hintereinander
gemacht. Die sieht komplett anders aus? Vielleicht war sie das auch gar nicht und war eine Fakerin
oder so. Die sah komplett anders aus? Was ist denn da los? Typisch US-Klag, okay. Ja,
wenn er meint, ist totaler Schwachsinn meiner Meinung nach. Hallo, hund69. Ja, genau noch
nichts und die sah ganz merkwürdig aus danach. Kann mich auch dran erinnern, weil ich gerade
gesagt hab, der Typ soll sich halt auf irgendwelchen Seiten ein paar Mädels nach Hause bestellen
oder irgendwo hin bestellen, wenn er angeblich sexsüchtig ist. Ich bin mal im Zug gefahren
nach Ulm und da saß ein Typ neben mir und der hat die gesamte Fahrt, wirklich, also
ein Aussteigen, Hinsetzen, der hat wirklich von vier Stunden oder so, hat er drei Stunden,
glaub Kaufmich oder was das war, hat der gebraust und sich Abendbekleidung gesucht und es war
nicht Elotrix, nein. Er hatte keine roten Haare, nein, er war das nicht. Da hat wirklich
drei Stunden, hat er komplett durchgebraust, alles, bis er die passende gefunden hat. Okay,
der ist da wirklich intensiv dabei, ja. Also, es kommen vielleicht zwei, drei Games in
Frage hier beim Sale, die ich mir kaufen würde, teilweise hab ich sie ja schon, der Rest ist
alles wieder ganz viel Shit irgendwie. PC Lustig hat er nicht gemacht, deswegen kann
er es auch nicht gewesen sein. Bist du kein Fallout Fan? Nicht so wirklich. Sebaro, keine
Ahnung. Das wollte ich mal spielen, weil ich das grafisch richtig gut gemacht finde, vor
allem mit dem riesen Aufwand dahinter. Soll aber recht schwer sein. Ahja ja. Oh nee. U-Boot.
Excellent. Da kann man dann unter Wasserstelz machen. Echo. Echo war doch auf dem, war doch
das mit dem Delfin, falls das noch jemand kennt. Es gab mal so ein 2D-Spiel, das hieß auch
Echo, da bist du mit so einem Delfin rumgeschwommen. Ob das auf irgendeiner Sega-Konsole. Äh,
hallo Max, ich hab mir heute Chromium erzählt, aber warum läuft Twitch nicht? Äh, es gibt
von Chromium mehrere Versionen, vielleicht hast du eine erwischt, die keine Codex drin
hat. Wobei ich dachte, es gibt keine Version mehr ohne Codex. Musst du mal gucken, es gibt
da ein paar Varianten von. Oh, das war, das war, das war nice das Game. Das hat mir richtig
gut gefallen auf der PS3. Moment. Ja doch, das ist das erste, das ist das erste. Was,
was für die Ayaya-Fraktion hier. Das war richtig gut. Wie oft wollen sie mal Cuphead
noch vorschlagen? Es gibt so viele Games, da blickst du überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Haben sie das auch Remastered jetzt? Nee, haben sie nicht, haben sie einfach nur für
den PC rausgebracht. Naja, was auch immer. Nachdem ich heute eh nichts Großartiges vorhab,
haben wir heute im Stream auch nichts gemacht. Aber es war trotzdem schön, dass ihr dabei
gewesen seid. Ich komm jetzt mal, ob ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen hab, die ich nicht beantwortet
hab. Hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir. Alter, das spackt
mir rum. Hatten wir alles. Wo ist denn der Speicherfestplatten für die Server? Na entweder
innen drinnen, eingebaut in den Plates oder auf dem Sand. Und ich glaube ansonsten hatten
wir alles. So, Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich geh jetzt pennen und nächsten
Stream hab ich zumindest schon mal eine grobe Ahnung, was wir machen. Schauen wir mal. Bis
dann, macht's gut, wir sehen uns, see you.